what's going on guys Mary here along
with Mike McCarty and we're gonna talk
to you guys about a creepy survival
horror game we played on the oculus rift
called narcosis super uncomfortable
you're underwater trying to survive but
it's not a horror in the traditional
sense there's not a lot of stuff to kill
you per se there's not a lot of gore
it's just unbelievably unsettling he's
claustrophobic it is mono phobic it is
hydrophobic it is all the phobias it's
just terrifying if you're afraid of
anything that has to do with water or
being inside and technical space this is
gonna mess with you they've found a way
to give you anxiety in most ways all at
the same time you are in the suit which
actually really helps with the way
oculus works right because you're using
a gamepad which might seem a little off
right why am I using a gamepad to walk
forward but when I can move my head
around in this world well the way
narcosis gets around that is because
you're in the suit when you move your
head around you'll see the inside of
your suit you'll see the borders of your
helmet but when you're moving you're
using your thrusters of your suits you
propel you forward through the water and
that kind of helps alleviate some of the
disparity that you feel mentally you
know when you're trying to play a game
in VR kind of helps convey or sell this
to your brain that you're in this suit I
think they did that really well yeah the
VR really adds to the sense of space and
it also adds the claustrophobia because
a lot of the times you're in these
really tight grottoes and like you know
moving among these rocks underwater and
that's one of the kind of hallucinations
come into play the horror elements come
into play when you're rounding hallways
and you see something that you know
shouldn't be there but it's just odd and
out of place and then you start to
question the character because money
that much of the story is told through
his monologues so then you start saying
well can I trust what he's saying or not
and that's where it becomes interesting
as you're kind of just
you know drifting through these old
abandoned corridors and whatnot yeah in
addition to your own real human brain
questioning yourself and wondering
what's going on down here and you know
did you see something moving you know in
the background there the game plays
tricks on you the game makes you
second-guess things that you thought you
saw the game is constantly messing with
you and you know it's a good testament
to the way they they kind of want you to
be paranoid they want you to not really
know your own mental state I think
amnesia did that really well where there
was a point where you know every time
you go scared your visuals became
distorted and it was really bad audio
cues it made you feel like you were
crazy and narcosis does that in the
sense where it lets you know that you're
breathing heavily it tells you that your
oxygen level intake is high and you
actually told me you scuba dive
that that's real that happens yeah
narcosis essentially when you're just
coming up too fast and you don't really
know what you're doing you can just
deprive your brain of oxygen and it
leads to this really weird sickness
where you your mind can play tricks on
you and that's why the horror elements
in this are you like we said they're not
traditional and it kind of comes into
you know it removes you even further
from the character because you're
inhabiting his body but you don't feel
safe at any point in time because you
know he might not be in his right mind
and you're at the same time you're
dealing with these survival elements you
know you're running out of oxygen
because your reserves are depleted and
now so you're going through these
corridors sometimes running into these
weird underwater monsters which scare
the hell out of your water spiders
they're the words they look like the
things like John Carpenter's monster and
it scared the hell of me the first time
because I was just I was dealing with
these hallucinations and I was dealing
with kind of always constantly worried
about my oxygen and they it does a good
job from what we played of encouraging
you to explore these really creepy
abandoned decrepit corridors but also
making you focus really hard on you know
your your vital signs your oxygen
and just all these things really
coalesce to create this odd you know
like disturbing experience and you can't
really play your finger on it for most
of the time this game gets quite surreal
and without giving away too much you
will find things that do not belong down
there and it will make you question your
own sanity is it down there and it's
just like a weird you know circumstance
that this would even get down here or am
I losing it and like losing my mind down
here and you know that's something that
even soma made me do sometimes when I
would wonder like is this all real I
just kind of just going nuts maybe this
is what happens when you have narcosis
and you start losing oxygen in your
brain that you start dreaming and
eventually you know you're dying yeah
these are like really creepy things that
happen over time this game brings out
the worst fear in in your own psyche so
I thought it did a really great job of
that yeah I really like how it plays
with my sense of space because a lot of
the hallucinations taking place kind of
they almost become puzzle elements right
when you're moving through these
environments and you're saying oh I
should go this way and I'll end up in
another place but clearly the
character's mind isn't working like that
and you know you start to question
whether it's the place you're in or him
and it also gives you this kind of
paranoia that like just seeps under the
surface this whole time and I'm really
looking forward to seeing whether that
can be carried through the entire
experience could we only play it I think
half an hour tops yeah and I really want
to see how they kind of use the
characters own
disturbed mentality to kind of let
itself to the narrative because that's
the appealing thing for me the more I
play it the more I want to see where
it's going where this character is
taking us whether it means to or not and
whether I can trust him because right
now I don't feel like I can I don't
trust anyone down there I don't trust
the spiders I'll trust that dude I don't
trust myself I mean that's really what
it's all them too it's like you're on
your own down there and you know it's
it's going to be really interesting to
see what they do with it not just for
the oculus and if you guys are
interested in oculus this game will be
coming out on PC and Mac as well so it's
not just a VR experience it's also you
know just for for us regular PC Mac
users so there's a lot to delve into in
this story and we will have to see more
when it comes out which supposedly is in
late spring 2016 which is no fear it's
not right I'm looking forward to playing
it thanks for watching guys
fear when the only options go